let's Kelvin chah's yeah no we don't
want to kill [ __ ] we want I mean
let's not die yeah we turn 18 young guys
in your lips Oh salty [ __ ] what is
that
we're salty lipped [ __ ] there's two
more phone hmm Oh I'll feel it wrong get
other salty no the hooks are gonna do
you no good cuz you're not going to
catch a single one of us how do we crack
Oh us we're far Russia's definitely not
cool he's lying here why would you know
well did he double jiggering you I think
it is space far he's rely on him wanting
me he's double jiggering you
he's rejiggering everything oh I think
it might be a quad backstab double cross
uh yeah yeah
quano double digger so is that like
eight crosses or is that 16 quad simple
math you do the average of the two I
didn't answer my question I'm just
saying well mark you have to find mark
you have to find the median and then you
have to take the first derivative ember
this from school this is why this is
what was why this was important yes the
first derivative uh-huh and that tells
you how many okay just get a derivative
according to what we have it's a first
derivative okay that doesn't make a lot
of sense but okay I don't think there's
any variables in there but all right now
just take the first derivative according
to GARP whoa what the [ __ ] is that what
the hell did I just see why it's okay
yeah all right on my hope it's like I
just saw et whoa whoa whoa whoa would
you call me hey hey your name I Jack go
left go straight go straight go straight
wrong consideration I heard differently
Wade I heard come on something I need to
you're right behind you - you're right
there's a door yeesh go through the door
without something to do tonight
yiii humming yeah I'm over here oh I'm
over here Fred
I hear you can I help ya just don't [ __ ]
it up or I'll be really pissed at you oh
wait I'm in trouble it left click and
then put space for really low Oh guys I
might be in trouble here you guys could
help me that's fine we're sacrificing
you for the cause mark that done a very
sensei can you not get that
alright that's him okay where are you
guys oh my god
okay you guys respect me at all hey keep
the other half that about
am I seeing hallucinations of you or
what yeah I'm driving you insane if this
guy does oh that's no good
please don't do that how we only let you
saw hallucination thank you nephew mark
that's what you sound like right now
don't do this oh dude please I'm
pleading my way
Howie generally aware that was violent
where it's always wait what are your
secret what are your abilities I don't
even know a shock therapy oh no that
does I have like a treatment thing where
I can only drive you guys insane uh-huh
my punishment phase where I can sleep
unless I come to psych come this way
okay okay okay all right I mean anyway
okay I'm scared and alone and well you
don't have the monster near you so shut
up see ya hey I don't want that so
comparing on don't y'all care be me
see all I gots a [ __ ] stop shock
they're being me yes stomp it come back
and weighs it so [ __ ] slow to repair
by whoa whoa whoa whoa buddy
why no oh my god
the hallucination not good for mean
goddamn oh [ __ ] you dear oh dear
I don't like funny that's bad that's bad
okay I don't find where the goddamn John
Waters are I've no I are you my friend
did I just get away are you are you did
you hey Wow look at you
worse wait is just the worst
you mean he is god-awful he is so bad at
being a killer
he won't get anybody dead oh that would
you stop shock therapy Gus yeah Jesus
right no longer afraid of your stupid
douchebag who appears in front of me
when you do that anymore
I'm not even clicking anything that's
just the insanity you guys have gotten
for being near me no I'm not no pain I'm
not insane my mommy had me tested uh-huh
why are you here is beautiful 'ti ah
this is not a treatment facility Howie
oh hey Mark hey hey what's up you doing
okay but let's try it way just try it
I'm a championship wiggler I've been
known today because you happen to be a
corner far away from everything
yeah I am yeah take some of this
wiggling Oh gonna get it right I'm
behind you I'm behind you
I've been pretty claw I'm going hard
guys I was pretty close
oh well I think I might be out of this
one guys I survived the trick in the
long road
down think I might be doing myself a
death think I might be getting a little
bit about it no less treatment think I
might be going away now how do I go well
here come here
hang on Oh
run oh my god come in run I wait hiya
bunny spring on are your club yeah we're
super good everything's awesome here
don't worry about it is it because I
think it's not awesome no come on
perspective it's not awesome I have
everything's awesome
you know what's making you go everything
is awesome everything is going alright
okay did you see a make on oh you've got
me I can never tell the killers don't
see very well and sometimes you could
just do I thought the quarterback Oh
jacket work done oh yeah
no I'm usually hey I could go punish
jackal I'm about to get hooked up here
if anyone is a struggle anyone's
interested in that yeah I'm struggling
oh I'm struggling keep struggling dudes
big guy huh yeah you know I can see
where you are right I can tell what's
happening and it's your party I pressed
are and he dropped the medkit what oh
yeah you can bring up items I didn't
know I can't think it back okay why
would you even know how that I'm glad to
be fine another item like if somebody
dies and drops their item you can switch
your item okay they mark we need to
spread out I'm concentrating
whoa hi hi hi Neha tree man coming wave
you just right oh right past me crouch
ticket so hahaha yeah you saw market you
really cool I'm gonna get it I was like
this alright never saw you I want to get
Jack why won't you guys just let me go
get you
Gudrun on it in prayer friend mm-hmm
exactly the kind of people you hold on
I'm waiting depends I mean like five
minutes ago
why did that miss that was a good skill
check that was a good one that was the
best one that was the best
nobody could still chuckling oh okay
wait mark mark you go straight mark keep
going straight okay I got you buddy all
right I see what you got going on
don't worry I'm real good at this
mark time to go time to go time to go
time to go time to go time to go buddy
oh [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] you found a friend huh
nah nah didn't you don't know that thank
you for being our friend no more for you
bet you did hook no don't hook him
don't dead hook him yeah Jake hook bro
wanna you wanna make me not this you
guys want to may not this I'm really not
save your for it well sorry marketer
save you no no no it's okay watch I'll
survive
I'm tough no wait number on that didn't
happen I died are you straight up dying
all the way already jumped in well that
sucks yeah sir Carter's been hooked at
yeah that really wasn't a fan base to
begin just will let me go into death so
looks like that happen bro we so good
right now
it was no idea whoops come on super key
why are you making that sound in my OOP
a way now you are going in the dinner
bell come get me buddy or Bob you're
just bad at that that was not good how
many generators do we need one more
third bomb left oh wait what do you mean
what is the same thing that's happening
but just stuff
I'm not going to skill tapping you're so
buzzing bait I'm being bait for Jack you
sure yeah that's what's happening by
intentionally being care about this
you've lost so much burgers out of it
ready I got two generators I don't want
to do it doesn't relieve the stress is
getting to me yeah
okay yeah I'm dead the stress got to be
you guys suck
and are bad and our Daryl hey hey friend
hey buddy
oh really fast now suddenly we did that
rekt oh [ __ ] you gotta react I don't
know how close we are to hook but I
don't think I'm gonna be able to wait on
my way free pride whoo hey face it bub
oh Christ
wait wait just hang on for about three
seconds just clapping yeah you're
hanging on bang and rolling and we're
all hanging we're off Riley I don't find
Jack pop trying to escape too late try
to escape you got this plot where are
you I want to play with you
Jack I doing great hiding a little no
not good that's the opposite of good
please friend please nope close knock
boyfriend
Aquagirl oh we're so not sacrifice we
are dying to be you made a GU you goofed
real good there to keep your Gupta [ __ ]
what [ __ ] really way I bet a real name
right now ah God [ __ ] oh okay okay
that was rude your feet do it York it's
insulting me Wow nice dick move dude
that's pretty good [ __ ] know what to
do when I can't move flat no you're
doing what you're gonna have to stop
sprinting because he'll keep knowing
where you are yeah that's good yeah
that's good
yeah gotta work good job
that's great that's great I don't know
how I'm not sure where he came from
actually wait seems to know things about
things that we don't know I saw him
through a doorway cutting across like
took a shortcut again yeah sure that
seems like a plausible thing Avenue I
believe that you can see it in what you
do like babe wanna ride for murder in
bed I guess two and a half generators I
was doing good yeah whatever I was doing
things I don't know he's actually like a
intense mattad so close clean up we got
away yeah well we made it for free in
hell hey Jack Jack did really great
thanks well I look like I have I at
score yeah looks like Bobby boy
[Music]